TALL-TALE GOLD MEDALIST
RYAN LOCHTE
HAS STARTED HIS FORGIVENESS TOUR
WITH AN APPEARANCE
ON THE NEW SEASON
OF DANCING WITH THE STARS.
IF EVERYONE'S DANCING,
EVERYTHING'S FINE.
AND THIS TIME,
HE WAS REALLY ALMOST MUGGED.
-LIAR! -GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOUS:
THERE IT IS.
PROTESTERS COME ON TO THE STAGE.
THEY'RE GRABBED BY SECURITY.
SECURITY TAKES HIM DOWN
RIGHT THERE.
-WHOA.
-(LAUGHTER)
-YEAH, MAMBO NUMBER FIVE-O.
UH, I WONDER IF THAT PROTESTER
IS GONNA TELL EVERYONE
THAT HE WAS ALMOST ROBBED. UH...
-(LAUGHTER)
-COMEDIANS, IT'S BEEN
NEARLY A WHOLE MONTH SINCE RYAN
LOCHTE'S CONTROVERSIAL RUN-IN
WITH A BRAZILIAN GAS STATION,
AND NOW HE'S DANCING ON THE TV.
I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO FEEL ABOUT HIM.
IS IT TIME TO FORGIVE HIM?
DO WE FORGIVE HIM?
ARE WE NOT OKAY WITH HIM?
-NO. -NO.
-WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
-WHOA! -DUDE.
-(LOUD AUDIENCE CHATTER)
THE AUDIENCE HAS
SOME VERY STRONG OPINIONS.
VERY STRONG OPINIONS.
A LOT OF SWEARING IN PORTUGUESE
FROM THE AUDIENCE. UH...
MOSHE, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YEAH, I'M TIRED OF THE ATTITUDE.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS ANYTHING
TO BE FORGIVEN FOR.
HE'S A HERO.
HE'S AN AMERICAN.
THAT'S HOW WE DO IT.
WE GO TO YOUR COUNTRY,
WIN A GOLD MEDAL, PISS ON IT,
AND THEN GO DO THE FOXTROT
BACK HOME.
-HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT.
-(LAUGHTER)
STRAIGHT UP, I'M TIRED
OF BRAZIL. I'M TIRED OF BRAZIL
WITH YOUR PERFECT-ASSED WOMEN
AND YOUR PERFECT BEACHES.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I GREW UP IN THE BAY AREA.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY
CAPOEIRA CIRCLES
I HAD TO PRETEND
TO BE INTERESTED IN GROWING UP?
-HARDWICK: YEAH.
-(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE & CHEERING)
GET BIT, BRAZIL.
POINTS. YEAH. CHRIS D'ELIA.
I THINK HE'S BETTER
AT DANCING AROUND THE TRUTH.
-YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN? HEY.
-WHOA! -WHOA!
BUT, NO. BUT HE DID GO TO BRAZIL
AND PEE ON THEIR THINGS.
I MEAN, IF I...
HE WENT TO ANOTHER COUNTRY
AND DID THAT.
IF I MISS THE TOILET BOWL AT MY
MOM'S HOUSE, I GET IN TROUBLE.
OKAY? DO YOU UNDERSTAND?
SO, LET'S, UH...
THIS GUY PISSED
ON ONE OF BRAZIL'S
MOST IMPORTANT LANDMARKS--
A GAS STATION DOOR, OKAY?
-(LAUGHTER)
-YEAH.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS, INSTEAD OF
FOCUSING ON MAKING AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN,
LET'S MAKE BRAZIL GREAT
FOR ONCE.
HARDWICK:
ALL RIGHT.
-(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE & CHEERING)
-YEAH.
SO MUCH
FOR FORGIVING HIM OR NOT.
I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT.
-AISLING.
-WELL, AMERICA,
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIM
DANCE OFF A CLIFF.
THIS IS SO INTERESTING--
THE WAY AMERICA PUNISHES
ITS WHITE MEN. ON A...
"WHAT'S THAT, BILL CLINTON?
YOU LIED UNDER OATH.
"WELL, YOU CAN BE DAMN SURE
YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO BE PRESIDENT
FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS."
-(LAUGHTER) -HARDWICK: YEAH.
-"WHAT'S THAT, RYAN LOCHTE?
"YOU VANDALIZE A TOILET, AND
THEN BLAME THE POOR BRAZILIANS.
"WELL, YOU CAN BE DAMN SURE
WE ARE GOING TO PUT YOU STERNLY
"ON ONE OF THE MOST
HIGHEST-GROSSING TV SHOWS
"IN THE WHOLE OF EARTH.
-NOW DON'T YOU DO IT AGAIN!"
-HARDWICK: LISTEN.
-(APPLAUSE AND CHEERING)
-"DO NOT DO IT AGAIN!"